it's crazy to think my friend and I  started out any treehouse and now we've  been to some of the weirdest places in  the world Olivia Axl Etra Lucas they  never gave up there's no way we were  gonna let a world this cool get torn  apart this is the greatest find of our  time that glow it's the work of a very  old group of builders a group so altered  they existed even before the order of  the stone whoa okay what just happened  people of Sky City a crime has been  committed there's a law saying people  can't build no unauthorised  boom check that out  Aiden had warned me you were dangerous  how about help you and your order of the  stone steal all the world's treasures  for yourself  Doolittle Adventure is over Jessie  you're going down  dancy someone else in this pod like can  you this was supposed to be my world  you